[Music]
so like I said in my review for Calvary
over the past few days I haven't barked
on a mission to see some of the smaller
artsy films that you guys have been
requesting me to review that I missed
earlier this year and the next one on my
list was the rover starring Guy Pearce
and Robert Pattinson this movie takes
place in a very desolate
post-apocalyptic Australia in which it's
like 10 years after a gigantic financial
collapse it looks very much like the Mad
Max World very desert II nothing's
really happening everyone looks dirty
and disgusting food is scarce fuel is
scarce and Guy Pearce is sitting in his
car in the beginning of this movie he
walks into a bar he sits there and
someone steals his car while he's
sitting in this bar he then embarks on a
journey to get his car back that's what
this movies about there isn't like a
gigantic plot it's a very simple film
along the way he meets Robert Pattinson
scare achter who is fleeing from
something that happened to him he joins
him on this journey and they embark
together to try to find Guy Pearce his
car sounds kind of dumb right it's not
the rover is pretty impressive as a
movie it looks incredible the
cinematography in this movie is gorgeous
and Guy Pearce always underrated is
fantastic in this movie he is so subtle
and so incredibly subdued in this movie
you can read so many emotions on his
face without him even saying a word he
looks so tired and worn down and once
you learn certain things about his
character that I will not spoil for you
the way he acts just makes perfect sense
this movie starts out kind of like Mad
Max and I was like wow this is really
really awesome very suspenseful the
first 30 minutes this movie were almost
perfect in my mind then the movie kind
of slowed down a little bit
I'm not saying Robert Pattinson is bad
in this movie he was actually really
good this is probably the best
performance that Robert Pattinson has
given that being said once his character
does show up I did feel like the movie
lost a little bit of its suspenseful
steam because then it became a lot about
these conversations between Guy Pearce
and Robert Pattinson and while they were
good and interesting I felt like the
movie is suspense just ended for a while
and then it started to pick up again
towards the end also there is a very out
of place pop song in this movie I mean I
was I get why it's there cuz I look
it up and I heard the director say why
he put it in but I'm sorry I actually
thought there was a mistake with the
movie when I was watching and I was like
why is this song here it didn't make
sense to me I felt like it was
completely out of place one of the
things I noticed a lot in this movie is
these guys are covered in flies
throughout a large majority of this
movie and these actors are being really
professional like they're just blinking
and like there are flies crawling on
their noses and on their eyes and stuff
and they're not even swatting them away
I was like guys you need some spray or
something but like I said in my review
for Frank one of the things about this
movie that made it consistently
interesting for me work the character
specifically Guy Pearce his character
he's such a loner you don't really know
anything about him and you were just
begging for information to figure out
why he looks so freakin mad all the time
and like I said once you do learn things
about his character it's like oh my gosh
this just clicks everything makes sense
now I do my best to always maintain
spoiler free review so I'm not gonna
spoil why he wants this car so bad all
I'll say is that once you learn why he
wants the car so bad I feel like it was
actually a fantastic ending and then it
made a lot of sense when you really
think about the things that happen in
the movie prior to it it's like a
strange Western noir post-apocalyptic
Mad Max all thrown into one there isn't
a lot of action it's a little bit slow
paced there's very slow editing lots of
long tapes in this movie so it's not
like an action-adventure but I think
this movie is worth watching purely for
guy Pearce's performance for one a
Robert Pattinson is best if not his best
so far and a simple story that's able to
build suspense out of thin air pretty
effectively I'm gonna give the rover a
B+ I did enjoy this movie so guys those
are some of the arthouse films that you
have been begging for me to see
I reviewed calvary and frank previous to
this i hope you guys do check out those
reviews as always guys thank you so much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]